okay so let's get start
so my pleasure to introduce paternal
Bandhan from the last talk of this
workshop and he's going to talk on
operations that preserve stability and
no hands invalid okay thanks for the
invitation so this is based on three
parts joint with Judas porchetta joon-ha
and Adam Marcus yeah so this may be the
worst title of the workshop very long so
some of you have seen the real title
I accidentally showed it no I was
inspired by a talk yesterday dreams may
come true with stability to see so so
this workshop is about hyperbolic
polynomials and high-publicity cone and
hyperbolic programming so let's start
with motivation concerning that topic so
if we have the hyperbolic polynomial and
its high publicity cone which we've been
talking about several times this week
then we may take the directional
derivative in the direction of any
vector in in the hypervelocity go and
then you get a new polynomial which is
hyperbolic again and the hypervelocity
cone relaxes the original high publicity
KO so we get a larger hyperbola silico
so I get a sequence of relaxation so if
we have a degree D polynomial then we
can do this D minus one time some we get
we we end up with a half space
and this map is of course a linear
operator and it preserves hyperbola City
and we know that the publicity combs
behave nicely under this operation too
so a general request so so this has been
used several times sin hyperbolic
programming by Jim Raynor gar for
example and they sometimes called the
renegade derivatives in that so a
natural question is are there other such
preservers and can we determine how how
they deform the high-publicity comes in
questions but our setting is somewhat
different so we are setting it is that
in terms of stable polynomials but we
shall see that these are the same
gadgets or their cousin sister at least
so a polynomial is stable well a
multivariate polynomial with real or
complex coefficients is stable if it's
nonzero whenever all the variables are
located in the upper half plane M for to
see one for this instead of the space of
polynomials to be closed we also want
the zero polynomial to be stable it's
just for convention
so this first guy is table
of course since the imaginary part is
positive here so if this is positive
imaginary part then this whole thing is
this is real stable for the same reason
and and this is stable because
multiplying two two numbers in the upper
half plane can never give you a negative
real number simple examples of stable
polynomials and maybe the for many
applications the important property is
that well if we if we're in one variable
then stability is actually equivalent to
being real rooted so all the roots all
the zeros are read if you start with the
mm-hmm and so what's the connections to
stable polynomials I've seen we've seen
I think we've seen this before so if you
if we do the how many if we homogenize
our polynomial then our original
polynomial is stable if and only if the
homogenized polynomial is hyperbolic
with respect to this vector here and the
hyperbola tsadikim should also contain
the positive orphaned in the original
variables so this is the how you
translate between stable polynomials and
hyperbolic polynomials so from now on we
will focus on stable polynomials and
step and the question central question
we will look at to begin with it is
which linear linear operators preserve
stability
so let's go back and look at some brief
history of this problem and why people
started it before and it's many problems
in mathematics goes back to this
variance of this problem well this
entire function so the Riemann
hypothesis is equivalent to that this
entire function here that you get from
the zeta function by clearing of the
poles and and and doing this linear
change of variables so that the critical
line comes on the real line but then the
Riemann hypothesis is equivalent to that
this Z function may be approximated
uniformly on compact by real rooted
polynomials or equivalently that all the
zeros of this entire function alright
and this was remands original statement
of there
so this was the maybe the original or
was the original motivation for hermit
ligerian Jensen apollyon others to study
this question of which linear operators
preserve realness but not all dreams
come true Wow
so there's been recent development by
yeah with the doubloon constant it has
not been successful you can agree with
that but what has been successful was
Lea and Yanks approach to the two-faced
transitions and they were inspired by
polios work on this on the Riemann
hypothesis so they so they in their
original proofs they use polyester salt
to to prove that the partition function
of the Ising model is non vanishing
whenever all variables lie in the right
half plane that by symmetry also got in
there left half plane so when you
specialize all the variables to one
variable all the all the zeros lie on
the imaginary axis many of yours are
familiar with the Liang theorem in the
version well this of the circle theorem
means that but this this is the original
statement
and that more recently there's been
interest in stable polynomials for in
combinatorial since stability gives many
inequalities among the coefficients that
are useful for premonitory X and also in
geometry and and even more recently
we've seen that the work of Mark is
Shrivastava on Spielman used stability
purpose per service - in the work of
Ramanujan graphs and the Caterson
senior problem and even more recently
we've seen beautiful work of an Aryan
and robust Quran in whether used
stability in computer science and in
particular for the Traveling Salesman
problem
so there's motivation or the briefest
with some simple examples of course
differentiating Purcell stability and
this is just the Gauss Lucas theorem
essentially so to set up we so this we
we start by looking at finite
dimensional linear spaces of polynomials
so again K is just the real numbers of
the complex numbers and we look at all
the polynomials of bounded degree so so
here cap by some vectors of positive or
non-negative integers and the
polynomials should be of degree at most
Kappa J in the J's and then there's a
convenient way to to encode the linear
operator so if you have a linear
operator from this space of polynomials
of bounded degree into this space of
polynomials we we make code the operator
in this symbol and of course it gives it
you can read off the linear operator
from it since this extra dollar is lists
so for example if we if we take this DD
X 1 then what we get is so so the first
so one of the first theorems on on
characterizing linear operators
preserving rewritten nurse was polio
ensures result from 1914 where they
completely characterized diagonal
operators preserving we do business this
was so so forth and then in 2009 Bertie
and I proved well we we were able to
characterize any linear operator
preserving well here complex stability
hmm so and the theorem is very well the
the condition is very simple that T
preserve stability if and only if the
symbol is stable but now in the double
the many variables instead this is very
simple so again if we take the
derivative well to prove that the
derivative preserves stability well we
only have to check that this is stable
but of course taking two numbers in the
upper half plane gives another number in
the upper half plane so it's nonzero so
these product of nonzero numbers which
is nonzero again so it's
and then hmm
the theorem looks a little bit different
for for real polynomials so now we
restrict ourselves to linear operators
of rank to characterize them in in rank
two and one two but but to save some
space we hmm so a linear operator of
rank greater than to preserve stability
if and only if the symbol is stable or
the shifted symbol is stable and this
can be seen well the reason for why this
appears is for this reason that this
linear operator preserves stability of
course like definition of the symbol and
a real rooted polynomial 2x plus 5 to
the power of M and instead of this can
you take like product of real roots of
polynomials in X Y
I don't know if it will give it and now
this this translates the upper
half-plane to the lower half plane but
since this since the coefficients are
real then complex zero comes calmly get
pair so so this operator preserves real
stability too and it translates between
these two so and that one may go over
too well if you want to consider not
finite dimensional spaces of polynomials
but infinite dimensional spaces we look
at the Legare polar class and the like a
polar class in n variables is the class
of entire functions which are limits
uniformly on kompis compact subsets of
CN of real stable for moments so for
example if we take e to the negative XY
well this is the limit of these
hmm so what is the symbol of a an
arbitrary linear operator well we cannot
do what we did before but we can do this
instead so so we you form this so this
is a formal power series a priori but
this is the transcendental symbol that
we want to work with and the theorem
just translates so that linear operator
preserve stability or instability if and
only if either the symbol is stable for
the shifted symbols in particular the
identity operator should preserve
stability and this is right so
so well maybe a bit surprising fact is
that we get sort of that this is an
entire function this has to be an entire
function in order for tea to preserve so
we just assumed that it was a six
so again an example then if we take this
operator that is easily seen to preserve
stability well at least by this theorem
then if we apply it to if we if we form
the the symbol then these wise jump down
and this is this isn't like a product
class and this is stable so the the
product of these two must be in the
lager product class again so this must
preserve stability so in particular for
if we want to look at one variable and
we want to look at linear operators that
preserve read rootedness this is if and
only if the symbols are in one of these
symbols are in the Legare product class
in two variables so a natural question
which I haven't seen an answer to yet is
if there is a transcendental version of
they haven't been binnacle theory
so the helped on binnacle theorem says
that any so if these if this is a stable
polynomial that in two variables then we
can you know in two real variables then
we can find symmetric a B and C of the
same degree for which the same size as
the degree so that well now for
stability we can this means that B plus
C is their identity matrix but what
would the health on binnacle theorem
look like for in this transcendental
version what would a B and C but would
determine
great home determinants over this is a
natural question that someone should try
to solve this is a nice example that
kept being an exponential phase is a
concrete situation such things no no we
saturate the siltation it's such an ER
representation there but then you would
so then you have to decide what the
determinant should be what is the
infinite determination different home
determinants very silly yeah so this
there should be an entire function
so now to something completely different
so we've seen discrete convexity in this
workshop to several times and we haven't
seen the name poly metroid but we've
seen the name M convex and I don't know
so that several synonyms to this so but
I like to call these gadgets poly
Metroid's or M convex sets so a finite
so we look at a finite subset of the
lattice CN and this is called a poly
Metroid if whenever you have two vectors
alpha and beta in your polynomial M and
the coordinates the ice coordinate is
bigger in alpha than in beta then we
should be able to move in the direction
to beta so so we should find some some
index J such that the beta is bigger in
the jth coordinate and that so that we
can move so we can add subtract the one
yeah one from alpha and add one to and
add one in the J's code or not so we
come in again it shouldn't have too many
holes and we should be able to move to
jump from one to another
yeah which is equivalent so there's an
equivalent version that you can actually
add that yeah that should be
Vader - - ej+
so it's the same so so if if if you
would have 0 1 2 then instead of Z and
this would be the basis change exchange
axiom
and how does it relate to polynomials
well if we have a polynomial we may look
at the support of the polynomial which
is the the indices for which the Taylor
coefficients are nonzero and then a big
paper from 2004 they notice that the
support of any homogeneous and stable
polynomial is always a poly metric I
don't know if you they did it for poly
mater but they did it from a TRO that
they left us as an open question if will
be can all polyMet roads or allmate
roads be be representable in this way
and fortunately or unfortunately
depending on how you see it this is not
the case so there if you take the panel
Metroid F 7 then it's not the support of
any stable polynomial
so we've seen COC polynomials before but
we like to call them Lorentzian and good
bits likes to call them that so so if we
represented a quadratic bytes Sen I
guess and if this has been well if this
polynomial or quadratic has non-negative
coefficients then it's not hard to see
that the polynomial is stable if and
only if a has exactly one positive eigen
value so the signature is plus minus
minus minus minus minus or it could have
some Syrian values to the signature so
this is how we define Lorenz a
polynomials so homogeneous polynomial of
degree D with positive coefficients is
strictly lawrencium if whenever you
differentiate it D minus two times along
the coordinate axis you get a polynomial
with Lauren's signature strict Laurent
signature so it should not be seen to be
non singular so whenever you
differentiate it D minus two times we
should get the Norns signature okay so
this is the strange definition of being
strictly roots
but we see since by this llama the this
well this essentially means that if you
if you differentiate D minus two times
you end up with a strictly stable
polynomial so this is sort of a a
relaxation of being strictly stable and
so then we so this is the open open
condition and we define a polynomial to
be the Lorentzian
if it is the limit of strictly lorrison
polynomials this is a quite well maybe
complicated definition so we could have
used this as a definition instead so so
it turns out that a homogeneous degree D
polynomial is lawrencium
if if and only if should be if and only
if here if and only the support is a
polymeric rod and whenever you
differentiate it D minus two times you
get a stable product or a or the the
Hessian is has has lower signature it's
the same thing
and one of the motivating polynomials is
the case this is the bivariate case so
what are these polynomials done well if
you differentiate t minus 2 times then
you just have to check 3 a polynomial
with three consecutive coefficients and
this the corresponding discriminant
should be non-negative and this amounts
to this exact condition which is the the
Newton inequalities so so for two
variables this is just a it relaxes
stable polynomials we rooted polynomials
to two just satisfying the Newton
inequalities so then fundamental
examples are as follows so if if we have
a polymer then actually the exponential
generating polynomial for their set
system is Lorenzi so any polyMet rod can
be represented as a Lorentzian
polynomial
and formate so if we if we have a mate
right now then and if we given the rank
function of the mate rod then we may
form the following which is a version of
the multi very tough polynomial and this
turns out to be lawrencium - which was
important for our application because
this gives this groups this masons the
strongest version of the masons
conjecture
another cute set of examples is that
relates to Carolyn's to Caroline's talk
yesterday is that if you have an M
matrix but a Caroline considered just
symmetric and matrices but the
definition makes sense for or non
symmetric matrices - and this is what we
have so we have any an a real matrix
which has non non non positive of
diagonal entries and all principal
minors are non-negative this is a nice
set of matrices and one way may prove
that actually the the mouth the the the
multivariate characteristic polynomial
in this axis
maybe what could into so it's another
version of the health time pinnacle
favor
hmm yeah so these are some examples from
that paper but the question we want to
ask is which linear operators preserved
there are neurons in property surprising
thing is that the same kind of
calculation hosts well not this is not
not a characterization now that it was
one they'd be the important direction
holds that if if we have a if you have a
linear operator whose symbol is
lawrencium so it doesn't have to be
stable but suffice it to be Lorenzi and
then the operator preserves the
Lorentzian property so as a so any so if
if the symbol is homogeneous and stable
then we know that it is Laurentian so so
T preserves the Ransom property is that
so so so this means that essentially all
if T preserves stability then and
homogeneity homogeneity then it
preserves the property so for example
differentiation or setting variables
equal but we can also get other kind of
operators such as this so say that we we
fix two vectors alpha and beta alpha
less than beta hmm and we we chopped off
all the coefficients which are not in
this
so this is sort of a
it behaves very nasty when it comes to
zeros of polynomials that it behaves
very nicely with respect to the
Lorentzian property so we can sort of
localized
and it's just yeah it's just to compute
this the symbol will will split up into
a product of the disjoint variables and
then you it reduces to the the
univariate case or the bivariate case oh
sorry yeah cohdon otherwise yeah so it's
a discrete interval yeah thanks for that
a box
and that's because when you when you
take a em convex set and you intersect
it with a box it still and yes you so
this is one of them it's actually a
consequence of the proof is just but as
a consequence we get Lois
and well a nice non-example may be
surprising to design or it it relates to
Nima's talk that if you if you if you
yeah if you take the inverse of the
variables and then multiply by by the
this maximum degree polynomial or
monomial then it then it's easy to see
that it preserves stability since the it
Maps the upper half plane to the lower
half plane all the variables but it does
not preserve the Ransom property very
much like it to
some applications would be nice
okay so do I have ten minutes left right
yes yeah yeah so we'll have time for so
then I come to the third part so it's
tries to say something about how how how
the zeroes so so now we know how to when
when the linear operators preserve
stability but we don't know how the
Siras move under their transformations
so to look at this first we look at the
symmetric symmetric additive convolution
studied by Markus shrivastava and
Spearman in a bit in there this is
defined as follows
and we want to look at the the maximum
zero of the or the largest zero so now
we we look at univariate problems and to
do this we we want to see how sort of we
first want to deform the polynomial by
by this linear operator and this linear
operator is easily seen to preserve well
we've seen examples of this before that
this preserves stability of this but
what Marcus shrivastava Speedman proved
was that that the that the maximum
serves behaves very nicely with respect
to this symmetric additive convolution
so this means that if you want to apply
if you want to apply this several times
you can sort of analyze how how this
series move because you can do this by
by by first multiplying by but by this
linear operator we we can get some
leeway and if we do that we can sort of
see that this helps us to see zeros
don't move too much
so this may be hard to appreciate this
if you haven't seen it before I must say
a feeling for it is the degree
and that leaked and writer proved a very
clean and nice theorem modularity which
which can seem to to to generalize this
theorem by taking age to be a certain
but if we're interested in weed stable
polynomials they don't have a max root
but what do we have well we have the
high publicity combs or so in the
literature this set has been cut in
called above the roots but I I don't
know it ought to be above the roots but
I don't know the above root set is a
good name so let's call it the high
publicity set
so the lab publicity circus is above the
roots so if you if you look at the
variety then it has a well it has a cook
a component with which is farthest away
to the infinity and about this where
nice they hyperbola so to set but
another way of seeing is it it is just a
hyperbola silicon sliced with this X 0
so it's a nice comics set and which sort
of which which is essentially B max root
so this is what we want to keep track
and indeed for a univariate polynomial
of this is exactly being above the
maximal the definition of the the
convolution is straightforward for
multivariate did we just do the same
thing
and it's easy to see that this
convolution preserved stability why well
we may fix we fix some stable polynomial
D and look at this linear operator and
if you do the do the yoga what you get
is G applied to this vector X plus y
this is a stable polynomial again given
that G stick
and yeah justice SEC is to prove that
this that if F is stable then F minus
some directional derivative of F along
the positive often is stable again
well we what we do is the transcendental
symbol and we get some linear form here
with the non-negative coefficients which
is
and now we want to look at sort of the
we don't just want to look at the they
have publicity set of F but we want to
look at the high publicity set of this F
minus D Omega and this is sort of one
way of seeing this is looking at some
cushy transform of F because if you take
D AMA graphed over F mrs. D
and I did there say there's a straight
well this that's a well but there's a
theorem that translates exactly has the
Maki Spearman and service tava theorem
hmm but instead with the high-publicity
sets
although the proof doesn't so the proof
is somewhat differently different we
have to sort of quite a bit harder
but what is nice is that well this this
convolution is as general as can be
because you can get any linear operator
as a convolution so if you have any
linear operator then it's just a cap
that an our umbral calculus exercise to
prove that T of T of f of X plus y by RT
acts on the X variables then it's
actually a convolution of this type with
the
with a simple so we can
so it implies it for example it unifies
all the different proofs of the
different convolutions considered by a
service you can get a unified proof of
all of them again you can get some
quantitative information for any linear
operator but sometimes it doesn't say
what it does
and even though leek and Ryder didn't
see this theorem they could conjecture a
theorem that would imply it's yeah I
think this should be one should be able
to prove it but I haven't yeah it's a
possible connection
it should give some general and this
should we can be that lifted up to the
theorem concerning any linear operator
and I'm I can use it to better
information on how the seals that is
this yeah hmm I don't have time to dwell
on this so I think any questions so in
the Marcus your Sava skill in papers
[Applause]
they use the univariate result often to
get nice rebounds but then whether go to
multivariate setting they often have to
resort to very function methods have you
traced with consequences of your theorem
are do you have like how far can you
push them and what kind of bounce they
get in this setting no wait
short us and I don't think we're getting
a better bounce on that for that because
they're pretty all the way
but you can get that bomb for Allison
singer well for example we can use the
symmetric convolution that because you
did I haven't tried to get any better
power series I think this this is still
not there's no way of sort of sort of
getting directly applying it to the
Caterson singer problem so this is this
is a defect of it so therefore we did
and here's a question and you know dream
come true
okay so let's end so the speed most of
the other workshop